pr nouvelle vidéo sur sub d'audika vous
avez été nombreux à vouloir une deuxième
donc c'est parti petite surprise geffard
mais le fameux minerai d'argent qui ne
voit qu est la dernière foire du coup
j'ai fabriqué le plomb pour pouvoir
fabriquer la combinaison un tir un lien
suivant croyez moi j'en ai chié mais
maintenant on l'a c'est parti on n'est
pas riche mais en moins qu'elle est
belle la canca ce qu'on me les ont
attirés dia sion deuxième petite
surprise geffard mais encore plus de
minerai d'argent c'est vous dire à quel
point ce fut dur pour pouvoir construire
un constructeur d'habitat ce qui fait
que grâce à ça on va pas reconstruire
des trucs encore plus ouf donc
logiquement on peut voir la [ __ ] si
j'ai à l'enfer une échelle un
observatoire et mon gars va pas refaire
une vraie base de toi ce vote a stick
alors tout se construit en titane le
couloir le truc le machin ou vador
pharma et titane
bah écoutez c'est parti allez on est des
fous petite base à la fin de cette vidéo
tu seras grande et hop là promet titane
où je peux attaquer maman c'est quoi ça
commence super mal je me suis jamais
fait attaquer dans ce [ __ ] de jeu
pourquoi c'est bon il nous a lâchés
arrête [ __ ] arrête arrête pouces et il
me traquent un laisse tomber bon pour le
mans on a plein de quartz le coincer
pour faire les trucs en verre oi ne base
va être entièrement faite de verre
vraiment et c'est bien moi y aura de la
lumière partout vous savez on pourra
bien vendre notre appartement après
quand on n'en voudra plus à ça je le
sens bien là je sens bien ça sa part sur
une grotte
non non non non s'en va c'est ça c'est
les gros trucs mais au final ils nous
attaquent pas ils sont pas méchantes je
crois qu'ils sont juste radioactifs mais
maintenant on est équipé pour les
contrer et je sais qu'on va avoir besoin
d' espèce de plante jaune que ya là bas
mais lebron s'excentre entre les requins
et j'ai pas encore d'armes pour se
défendre
du coup on va rester avec nos petits
morceaux de calcaire a tant qu'à faire
un hard et on prend aller retour à la
base on va grandir tout ça on va
commencer par faire un couloir en u i
c'est un bon début
comment je fais s'il vous plaît à
d'abord faire des fondations à
construire en premier est-ce que c'est
malin de la mer juste à côté de ça on va
la mettre un peu plus loin du coup
claque au ça se construit petit à petit
d'accord et ensuite on peut mettre ça au
alors gala est par contre faut mettre
une entrée etc outils nécessaires pour
pénétrer dans la base alors vas plus de
titane pour la faire du coup je sais ce
qu'on va faire on va faire du verre en
masse comme sa voix ça sera très très
beau ça on adore être dedans attend
c'est un bon début de base un bond sera
mais qu'on pourra rentrer dans un ce que
j'aimerais bien faire aussi syllabaire
véhicule mobile comme ça on pourra
construire des véhicules
il nous faut ça vous voyez je l'avais
dit que ça ne servira qu'à tchekhov
[ __ ] le devin lubrifiants oh la la
merci et du coup attention est ce que
c'est cool alors comment se sert de sa
déployer la baie de véhicules
là haut au truc qui est sûr c'est que ça
et maintenant un cyclope ce alors la
mecque on a trouvé notre nouveau but
il faut du lingot de plascassier du
verre émaillé dû leur salut à compliquer
lingots de plaques d'acier
donc il faut des lingots de titane
chaque langue occitane ses 10 titres
[ __ ] et du verre émaillé il faut une
dent de rôdeur web tu vois ça va être
long et périlleux mais c'est une bonne
nouvelle ça vous savez les débris
métalliques on peut les prendre il est
désintégré pour obtenir du titane bah
ouais et on peut aussi fabriquer ainsi
glide maintenant a converti le mouvement
de torsion ont poussé sous marine via
son hélice assez pour aller plus vite et
il manque le lubrifiant à va falloir
aller couper dans la vigne à cela avec
les requins autour ça c'est pas très
cool du coup la vignasse c'est par là
bas regardez on les voit à regarder on
les voit briller ah non ça c'est le tuer
des monstres [ __ ] je suis bête aux
mecs on voit rien
du tout c'est la pire zone du monde
obtient rock et en y en a un là [ __ ]
on est tellement dans la merde
non non non j'en ai tout haut que aidez
moi s'il vous plaît aux ils ont fait
péter leur truc là-bas vous avez vu a du
coup peut-être que quand je me fais
attaquer je m'approche de zeeuw en fait
ils m'aident
[ __ ] de cons avons tué à la dernière
fois en fait faut juste leur bassin
agricole non je vais mourir j'ai pu de
vie un quiz mort non pitié hockey
logiquement on a ce qu'il faut c'est bon
on en a ramassé plein en fait c'est des
graines faut les ramasser faut pas
couper la vie mais voilà je suis débile
et là avec une grande émotion ou compris
le sigle ied au et en plus ya une langue
à part au delà de l'énergie ça c'est
chiant mais mon cas on est tellement
bien alors du coup on va pouvoir
construire l'entrée de satan fait mille
trucs à la fois c'est génial squeeze
ingénieurs et voit la puissance 0 / 0
alors comment faire pour donner de la
puissance panneaux solaires a construit
sur un sol en soleil et pour recharger
olala c'est génial mais regardez ça lui
ça le nourrit en énergie on en met un
petit deuxième mais là mais là mais
c'est génial
ah ben voilà on peut mettre que
fabricateurs qui nous permet de kraft et
des trucs là comme ça on n'aura plus
jamais besoin d'aller dans le petit que
le petit canoë kayak c'est parti la
chasse au titane est ouverte on va
essayer de choper des débris métalliques
pour les faire frontières a beaucoup
plus vite
ben voilà regarder au le mec à peine il
dit ça il en trouve
on va mettre les fabricateurs justice''
ouf de petites bases à nous et voilà on
n'aura plus jamais besoin d'aller dans
ce [ __ ] de canoë salle multifonctions
alors je sais pas à quoi ça sert mais on
va quand même faire ça dans le doute
allez allez on se construit la salle 1
je suis tout ému [ __ ] c'est comme un
premier appartement et du coup là j'en
fais quoi de cette talent j'ai construit
je suis heureux mais qu'est ce que je
peux [ __ ] dedans 20 minutes de
construction [ __ ] squeeze out une
révélation
en fait je suis content j'aurais dû
faire la base ultra profonde et comme ça
j'aurais pas besoin de nager pour des
millénaires à chaque fois m
si c'est triste à mai ces parages peu
tous des membres est en fait voilà et ça
me redonne du titane fleuve si c'est
cool engagera tir aux lots on peut la
mettre n'importe où regarder on va la
mettre là on est déjà 47 mètres c'est
très bien ici on va refaire le fameux
couloir la fameuse entrée et puis on est
bon et ben voilà on regarde et on est
déjà à quarante capteur de profondeur
quand on est dans notre base ce qui fait
qu'on va vraiment pouvoir aller très
profond regarder le petit couloir en
vert on voit à travers ça mais il y en
aura c'est mignon mais si on voit un
gros rock arrive et ça va être beaucoup
moins mignon pour le fun j'aimerais
quand même construire un petit aquarium
je peux même pas voilà le je veux pas eh
bien écoutez je propose qu'on termine
sur la construction de ce petit scanner
voir à quoi ça sert alors je crois qu'il
ya des petits blocs des fois qu'on
trouve il faut les scanner je sais qu'il
faut scanner ça voilà exact à la chance
mais je me suis demandé à quoi servait
ses gros blocs de sel entrer dans ce
court billet débloquer simone fragments
des sims numériser le progrès sont 20%
alors le seul truc que je me demande
c'est comment on recherche nos véhicules
parce que la voyez il reste que 48 %
d'énergie à ce truc très utile et quand
on va tomber à zéro l'apl est un
fragment à analyser mon gars je me
demande vraiment à quoi ça sert [ __ ]
peut-être qu'on découvre des nouveaux
cracks
je sais pas encore trois et on aura la
réponse prouve tout simplement qu'on ait
défense est l'un de ces connards de
requins et je pense que c'est cédant à
lui qu'il faut plutôt regarder le passé
ça riait s'étendre honneur qu'il nous
faut c'est leur honneur à sa part en
courant saloperie de l'âge de merde et
heureusement j'ai ça je pourrais jamais
le suivre il va beaucoup trop vite
il est mort non il ay la pichot un
débris mer il veut pas mourir j'ai vu de
couteau je vous laisse j'ai cassé mon
couteau sur ce truc examens possibles
eh ben je crois ces débris métallique et
je m'en vais à vila routard pour nous
réconforter
on trouve un petit fragment si ça ça
fait pas plaisir mais revient mais
calculée non pas tant que je suis bien
pour elle son couteau ap ap ap ap ap ap
ap ap ap ap ap ap ap ap paris bye bye et
panique
allez commencer pour adresser ses dents
s'il vous plaît aux objections honneur
et je peux rien faire il ya un truc
c'est impossible
ben voilà on finit sur un un move nul et
j'en suis fière de cette seconde vidéo
sur sub nautica n'était pas allé mais ça
vous a plu je suis fier de nous on a
construit une base on a fabriqué un
petit véhicule
on a tué un rôdeur mais on n'a pas pu
lui arracher les dents c'était génial
vraiment là on est on est épanouie
écoutez ça partira sûrement sur une
troisième vidéo à fasse mentir pas de
cachotterie d'entre nous un berceau
regardant cette hausse et les deux
prochaines vidéos portez vous bien que
tout le monde au pis